we are destroying the things that keep
us wealthy and that is that is really
the purpose of T to try and time bring
those things out into the into the open
now this is a paper you might have
recognized from nature 2009 Rock stroma
tell from the Stockholm resilience
Institute they did a survey of the
impacts of humanity on planetary
homeostasis they decided that since the
last ice age the the earth has been
fairly equable for life and we are now
putting strain on that which is putting
that Thome estate is in jeopardy and the
of the things that they they recognized
and I'll just mention that this green
border here is what they regard as the
safe limits of these things biodiversity
on the on the left here is is
hemorrhaging from the planet we are
losing bird last year about a thousand
times the natural background rate of
loss we as everybody knows we're as
nearly everybody knows we're pumping
carbon dioxide into the atmosphere at a
rate which is making the the planetary
temperature unsustainable and we're also
producing so much phosphorus and
nitrogen nitrogen particularly but
phosphorus is nearly up to the limit
that we're fertilizing the broader
environment we use nitrogen and
phosphorus to to add to our crops so
that we can grow more crops and more
cheaply but that's leaking into the
broader environment and causing problems
of what they could lead trophic ation
again to repeat that environmental
sustainability and economic
sustainability should be the same thing
they are the same thing if you look at
the figures and work it out and take
care to our natural capital is depleted
this is going to be covered in other in
other lectures anyway but because our
natural capital is depleted all the
things that that keep us comfortable are
our social political economic well-being
are compromised in fact they are
impermanent because of the depletion of
the natural capital so we know from
studies such as Hooper a tower which is
on the reading list that some high
biodiversity increases productivity in
an ecosystem
the more space species that you have
within an ecosystem the greater the
production of primary production that's
growth of plants and algae and so on and
secondary production that's animals that
eat the plants so that we can we can
expect greater productivity and in in
line with how many species of there it
also brings greater variation in species
the more species there are the more
chances that that they will have
different characteristics from each
other and that's very important with
something called response diversity when
an ecosystem is put under pressure from
an external driver like an invasive
species population growing or
temperature change or eutrophication
this fertilization of nitrogen
phosphorous the different species
comprising the ecosystem react
differently they handle that in
different ways so that when if some of
them are lost then other species can
continue the function the other thing
that's high biodiversity leads to is
greater chance of having keystone
species keystone species are unusual
species in that they have a very great
effect on the ecosystem a typical
example much cited is the beaver if you
have two ecosystems one of which has
beavers then you're going to have water
lakes dams and wetlands processes going
on in that ecosystem that you won't have
in the one that without the beaver and
so that's a characteristic of that
ecosystem buy it from one species which
is unusual so it brings me to the
question that should have asked in the
beginning which is what is biodiversity
and the BBC did a survey amongst them
various cities in in England in Britain
and when the teep d0 document was
published it was on the news and they
did a survey and they asked people what
they thought biodiversity was and one if
anyone can guess what the top answer was
from the highly educated British public
what anyone have a guess
number of species not remotely close the
top answer was a washing powder and that
really ought to spell out the level of
ignorance there you thought of that
because you knew but in fact it what it
tells me is that it's up to us it's up
to people prepared to study this
economists ecologists academics
policymakers is up to us to solve the
problems of biodiversity and the fact
that we depend on them for so much